over the weekend we saw activists show
up at churches throughout the country we
thought this one was interesting because
this one actually is in los angeles and
phoenix my ap here he was actually
baptized in this very church in los
angeles and you can see abortion
activists who showed up to disturb the
catholic
you or mass we are not attacking anybody
[Music]
get out of here
christian things when you're out there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
get out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
strange they never tried in mosques
isn't that weird um now there's of
course a gajillion levels of irony there
and ridiculousness first off they're
doing this in california california is
going to be the abortion capital of the
world gavin newsom will gladly rip the
babies out himself and spew their blood
all over his face just like was that too
much too much imagery that was a bit
much oh no you like that one okay i
thought michael has given me one of
these that's usually dave you've gone
too far but you were actually giving me
one of these um so the fact that they're
doing this in california is ridiculous
that's number one number two
religious institutions are allowed to
have their own beliefs on things the
catholic church or a jewish temple or a
muslim mosque etc are allowed to have
their own religious beliefs when it
comes to marriage abortion or a whole
series of other issues you do not have a
right to come in and burst into their
services and use your free speech to
impinge on their free speech that is
that is the negotiation we have with
speech right
and it's strange because you never see
the pro-lifers just bursting into
abortion clinics uh you know it's
happened over the years right years ago
there would every now and again be a
crazy person who would do something to
an abortion doctor or clinic and of
course it should be condemned fully
absolutely condemned fully but the point
is that you're not going to see anybody
on the left condemn any of this and then
we just got three
images of just some of the stuff that
are being written on churches and on
schools and buildings if abortions
aren't safe then you aren't either
tolerance that's nice my body my choice
on uh sacred heart of mary church right
there and what's interesting about the
my body of my choice people of course
are these are the exact same people
almost without exception who were
demanding that you get injected
right they didn't care about your body
right they wanted me to get ejected with
something that i chose not to get
injected with and i'm very proud that i
stood up against the machine and did not
get injected with it and i meet all
sorts of people who stood up and did not
get injected but they really wanted
control over our bodies they were demand
no one's demanding anyone get an
abortion but they were demanding that we
get injected with something to either
keep our job or be a respected member of
society so these are obviously
hypocrites usually buffoons and morons
and not very good people who have any
understanding of what a exchange would
be like in a free society